Hello everybody my name is Markiplier.
and welcome to Case Animatronics.
Now this is supposedly not
A "Five Nights At Freddy's" fan game
But... the comparison might be made,
considering what I see thus far
in that it looks like a computer terminal monitor
and there seems to be an animatronic
*pissed off tone* and it says animatronic right there
in the name of the game!
But I will reserve judgment
because that's what I do.
Do not forget to wear Head-phoanes.
Game could-
Nevermind, no warning for anybody
You're going into this raw
and unprepared.
What is that?
Huh... you've got...
*rough voice* I'll go check
I've got a lot of self entitled dialog going on here.
Huh, good thing I've blurred out all those documents
on my computer! Time to go check.
Got my flash light here,
let me hold it military style.
*rough voice* Do you appreciate my sarcastic sense of humor?
It's really going to help me
Oh, probably not a lot
if it's given out by corporate
I don't know about that
Probably animatronics, are gonna...
Why am I talking to you? When I was just talking to myself a little bit ago
Maybe I'm just a little confuzzled
*Normal voice* Okay
I don't know!
Well... This is a rather bizarre and disorien-in-ating
tutorial introduction,
but I'm going to go out there
in the fuckin' dark... holy shit...
Where am I going? What am I doing?
Why...? .... What was that?
Did you hear that?
Ooh... well that ain't good.
...Okay... alrighty then...
Hello- ah good, I'll turn that off!
Didn't want the light anyway.
*rough voice* Better this way in the dark
by my own self
alone with my thoughts.
*normal voice* Mm-Kay
Alrighty then
Fuck off
Mm-kay (That face though)
Oh this door's closed- thanks for telling me that, I could of looked at it and do that
but you decided to give me a.. Oh hey
Hi why are you covered in blood?!
Why do you have such short stubby legs?
Sorry to insult your height but
it happens to... ooh hey
but it happens to me all the time on the internet.
Were you... were you looking at me?
I think he was looking at me... a little... bleh
Okay
Wait- 119... *singsong* I cant read that laaast leeetter~
1197... I bet it is!~
Is that a coooode? Keycard, huh?
Okay.. YOU HAVE FUN STAYING ON THE GROUND FOREVER
AND NOT GIVING UP AND SHOVING YOUR ENTIRE SELF INSIDE ME!
Er, wait, the other way around, woah hang on
I meant the stuffing of the - in the suit, not... (Suuuuure Mark)
Wow! Okay, never mind then.
Holy shit
Alright
So I need to find a charger
We're gonna ignore everything that happened
Oh okay what's this (HEADPHONE USERS RIP)
Ohhhh
(jumpscare) OH FUCK OFF! (has a heart attack)
WHAT?!!
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME?!
WhAt tHe FuCk?!!
Ohhh... that was all part of the plan.
K
Okay...
HI
Sure is
(Mark.exe has stopped working)
(Rebooting may take a year)
(Rebooting is almost done, please do not close down Mark.exe)
HUH, WE WOULDN'T WANT ANY MORE-
Oh god not again
Why do I gotta move back to the control room?!
We wouldn't want any sort of deja-vu incident!
I'm gonna die.
In horrible, horrible ways.
And it's all gonna be ca- oh, hello! Um...
Alright
So why did he say apartment?
Hello, handsome man, how are you doing?
Why did he say apartment
when... I'm obviously in a police department
office? Maybe?
Ooh boy
Oh that's sounding good
*Inhale*
Is that the same thumpy thump that got startled me before?!
Is that the same animadroomic?
Again, is that a two?
Okay... 3922?
Let's try it again!
Same old deal that we did before, I guess
3922 (2x)
Huh, keycard...?
Helloo
HuH?!
I DON'T WANNA KNOW WHAT THAT WAS!
I'M NOT GONNA OPEN MY GODDAMN EYES
I'M GONNA STARE AT THIS PANEL LIKE NOTHING BAD HAPPENED AND THEN MAYBE IT'LL GO AWAY!
three - nine - two - two
Well,
How 'bout that?
Hmm.
Wonder what's gonna happen a-here?
*tiny voice* okay
What the hell is the second plate?
I dunno what you're talkin' about.
You're being a lot less descriptive than you were before!
Is this the second plate?
Nooo, that's just the thermostat.
Holy shit!
*rough voice* I know!
I can't be too scared about anything!
Can't show too much emotion...
I had my amygdala removed, don't mind me.
I can't say the word 'amygdala.'
I got a lobotomy when I was 12 years old.
Oh... hello... hi.
It's Batman? I should've known!
There's a gruzzled voice man who's Batman.
Okay.
Alright then.
Gotta find where the other drugs are going...
Alright, so, I'm guessing that animitromo...
is gonna be up and walkin' around now...
Uhuh.
Hoho!
It is mysteriously gone...
Hello?
No.
I dunno.
Hmf.
Play WHAT?
(sound warning)
OhKaY.
Ohk- (sound warning again)
AH!
Wha- I don't know what I fucking expected!
I guess- I didn't think it was going to open!?
Oops.
Whoops. WHOOPSIES.
I didn't mean that to happen.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Let's try that again!
Oh. "May be too intense for pregnant women."
Well that rules me RIGHT out.
Okay, let's *laughing* try that again!
*Laughter*
Alright. Okay. Alright.
Let's do this... Skip the dialogue
*half-heartedly* Ahhh!
Alright, NOW we run!
Oh
Wher- Where?
Alright fine, this one I guess.
I bet this is gonna be good.
Hmmm.
Where's the dialogue that's gonna go,
"What the hell was that?"
"I hope that thing's not trying to kill me."
"It was like some sort of animatronic. I probably should hide."
Hello!
"Oh, it's right outside the door!"
"Huh, good. It didn't seem to spot me."
(Mark waits... semi-patiently for animatronic to leave)
A-Am I free now?
Okay!
That's not-
That's-
That's not a good sound...
I'ma hop right back in here!
*Listens intently*
Alright, I'm assuming it's gone.
So wher- ooh.
wutwuzat?
Ooh. It's-it's out there.
Ooh. That ain't-
That ain't good
Where's this other panel?!
Oh, TITTY SPRINKLES.
I went the wrong way!
Ah shit.
AH SHIT DICKS.
WOOOAHHH
*Bigfoot call*
SHITTY DICKS
Can I crouch?
I can't.
I'm fuuuubbernucked.
Ah. I went the WRONG way.
Ooh, I went the wrong way...
OH
I know what I'm supposed to do. (You sure?)
I'm st-
I'm supposed to go BACK... through the door that-
Ah.
This-ooh.
EHAY?
Well-AHHHHHHH!
AHHH IT'S CLOSE
*Unintelligible squeals*
UhOH
uHoH
UHoh
uhoh
Wooaaah.
Kay. GOOD THING IT'S NOT VERY SMART.
GOOD THING I AM THE SMART ONE HERE (Sure)
Can I close this door?
Yes I CAN!
It will never be able to get through NOW!
I've out-witted it!
I am the smart.
Kay what now?
The hell's another panel?
Can't see shit with stupid flickering lights.
Well, that had nothing in-
Well, that was pointless.
Goddammit, I can't see shit.
Wh-I dont need to HIDE?
Doesn't help when you're shining your flashlight
out the stupid doorway.
So there's gotta be like
another panel or something around here somewhere.
Oh! That's convenient!
Huh.
Uhh...
*Do not want*
...Hey
Oh good! There's a giant thing
In a giant crate!
That's probably helpful for me!
Maybe I can unleash it, and just get them to fight each other...
That'd be nice.
Hey, stop that! That's government property.
Ooh hey.
Hi, 'friend'.
Who the frick are you?
Are you from 'Five nights at Candyyyyyyyy's?'
Where's this panel?
Wheres the goddamn panel??
I would've thought that it would've been in here.
I mean, this looks exactly like the kind of place that would have a panel.
Can I open this? No.
Well dangit.
There ain't no panel in here.
Alright then. CARRYING ON.
Agh. I have a feeling I'm supposed to find like a keycard. (sound warning)
Oh.
Good thing I a- wut- woa-
AHHHHHH
FUCK, MAN.
HOOOOOOOLY shit
Haaaa. KAY. WELL.
LIKE I SAID;
I IMAGINE I'm supposed to find a keycard.
And that's going to help me get to other-
Where the hell am I now...?
Where am I now?
Why am I over HERE?
Oh goddammit.
Well, I guess I didn't get very far...
Okay, so, my imagination, once again, tells me there's gotta be-
a keycard around here somewhere.
I just gotta find it and eat these doughnuts
Om Nom Nom Nom
Good doughnuts!
Maybe it'll be mad at me that I ate all of it's doughnuts.
Do I give a fuck?
The answer's NO!
Hello
Can you- Thank you.
*Reading the note on the screen*
Oooh. Interesting. (You didn't even read it slow enough to absorb it.)
Is this the words of the guy on the phone?
And- and somehow-
I stole Emma away from her?
him*
Is that what I'm supposed to be led to believe?
You never know with these things.
I remember seeing another note in here somewhere...
I don't know if it's randomly generated or if it's all just...
very, very spesific layouts.
Seems to be randomly.
Eat the doughnuts!
Don't get mad at me!
Gotta get the last one!
Ah there we go!
*Reading the note on screen*
ohKAY?
Very confusing...
Doughnut break! *Nom Nom Nom*
I always get... so hungry when I'm scared...
Oh, herro.
*Reading the note on screen*
ohKAy
Interesting thing to write out...
I'm not sure how that pertains to ME?
Hello, more story....
*Reading note on screen*
*gasps* CAN HE GET ME WHILE I'M READING THIS?!
He'd better not...
*Continues reading, stressfully*
okAYYY
I'm about to die, aren't I?
Dammit...
After getting this far... (Mhm...)
Man, I don't even know if I'm on the right track for getting a KEYCARD.
I do not think that I am...
*Sigh* Seems like he left me alone for NOW...
But I've gone through just about EVERY drawer that's accessible to me,
because I must be doing this, like, some wrong way...
There- I must not be doing this quite right...
There must be something that I'm missing...
Like altogether there's something...
There's a piece of the puzzle that I'm not putting together...
Woah! Hello!
Wow! Did not notice the bathrooms!
Why are the bathrooms...
...Here?
Okay, where am I on...
I'm not where I need to be...
Close, but not where I need to be...
*Finds keycard*
OH!
HELLO!
HI!
*rough voice* 'Ungh it's a keycard, huh? Well...'
Door's locked with a keycard...
Too bad I only have *this* keycard...
*Normal voice* Okay, so...
As I recall...
There were only a select few keycard-locked doors...
One of them...HELLO!
Hi, 'friend'! How are you?!
Woahhh boy! Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy!
Welp, in the closet.
You never saw me!
I got a keycard!
I did not know it would just be lying on the ground in the locker room.
I don't know why I didn't kno-
*Do not want*
*Not ready for Freddy*
(You okay, Mark?)
*Mark.exe has crashed*
(Don't worry, Mark, we'll throw you an amazing funeral.)
It's right there...
*MANLY SCREAMS*
Hi-heh-heh-heh
Oh my god...
AHHHHHH Shittytits....
OKAY! Um...
So I got the keycard...
That is good PROGRESS!
But not exactly what I wanted to do.
So I'm going to end this episode here...
Because I got more to figure out soon...
But I got a few pieces of the story,
and I got a few spoops.
That was actually terrifying.
Being able to see the thing standing outside the door,
that's a nice touch.
But, Five Nights at Freddy's fan game, this still is.
So, THANK YOU everybody so much for watching,
and as always...
I will see you...
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BUH-Bye!